hey guys it's justine and today we are
checking out the brand new insta360 link
now insta360 is mostly known for their
incredible array of 360 and action
cameras but today we're getting a first
look at their entry into the webcam
space and this isn't just any boring
webcam it's a 4k ai powered webcam with
a half inch sensor a 3-axis gimbal
built-in algorithms to track your
movements hdr and dual noise canceling
microphones there's also specialized
modes for whiteboard enhancement
portrait live streaming desk view and
more so let's open it up and see what's
in the box
look at you
wow okay so this is deceiving because on
the box it looked so much bigger than it
actually is i mean i guess it's
technically the same size but this looks
like a tiny little gimbal look at you
there it is
let's peel off these stickers
i also like this has a little mounts
that you can put this on a tripod and
we've got a usbc port here on the back
and this flips down so that you can just
position that on top of your monitor or
your macbook or pc or whatever it is
that you have we've got our accessory
box here what could be inside
it's already the mystery
looks like we've got a usbc to usbc
cable it's pretty long too which is
great because a lot of times you need a
longer cable so that you can attach your
webcam to either a desktop device or
maybe your computer is far away so this
is super helpful
i got a little cleaning cloth that's
nice let's clean your little eye there
you go all clean
it's like we have a little dongle here
to convert from usbc to usb-a
that's lovely four stickers where am i
gonna put all of those my goodness
insta360 loves their stickers okay we've
also got some instructions here
that's cool
okay there is the whiteboard mode and
these are the stickers that you actually
need to define the definition of where
the whiteboard is so justine good thing
you read the directions and i advise
everyone to not do as i do we have one
more thing this is a mini two in one
tripod i love all of the insta360
accessories very cool
i mean this is such a mini tripod that
is so tiny so now we have everything
unboxed let's take it over to my desk
and get it all set up and test it out so
i have the webcam all set up i'm so
excited to try this out i already have
the software installed it comes with a
free downloadable software called
insta360 link controller and this is it
right here this will give you access to
various things like controlling the
gimbal image settings and there's even a
more settings settings where you can
configure the gesture settings there's
ai zoom options and there's other
various things like streamer mode hdr
mirror image and a place that you can
update the firmware so right now we are
in the gimbal control setting so this
gives me the access to use this little
toggle right here and i can move this
gimbal all the way around my office look
at that like look how far it's going
it's basically going all the way towards
the wall now instead of using this
little toggle to bring it all the way
back around i can just double tap right
here on the front and that will bring
the camera automatically back to center
now there's a preset position section
right here so you can have this preset
various positions and when you're in
like a live stream or you're on a
conference call you can just click over
in this app and you can change those
settings and it'll automatically
translate over to whatever you're
streaming on or on your conference call
and down there it is another thing you
can do is actually record in the app so
right now i am recording so i'm going to
give you guys that demo one more time
we're in our normal position and now i'm
going to zoom
yeah
and then we're going to go back to
normal
and then we're gonna go to our downward
angle that's so great like this is like
you have a whole tv studio right here at
the palm of your hands
now this desk view you may have seen
that apple is now doing something
similar to this in their latest version
of ventura and using your iphone as a
camera it's using this camera lens and
ai to correct the distortion to make
everything look like this is almost an
overhead camera which is so cool
we can all watch tick tock together
this also has an overhead mode so a lot
of youtubers and content creators love
having that overhead perspective which
you actually have already seen in this
video of me unboxing but this allows you
to easily mount this camera because it's
so small and the rig that we have now
like these cameras are heavy this is so
small and it's so portable so compact
that you can get an overhead camera
almost instantly and the fact that this
is 4k you're also going to be getting
really high quality because this is on a
gimbal it lets you automatically have
the camera be pointed directly down so
it'll be leveled it'll be centered and
you don't have to worry about making
sure if your tripod is level or not
because the gimbal automatically will do
that for you the other thing is testing
out the audio on this camera i'm excited
to see see i'm excited to hear what that
sounds like it does have two noise
cancelling microphones on it so i'm
excited to test it out and right now the
audio that you're listening to is the
audio that's coming directly through the
insta360 link love to hear it the
gesture settings in this is also what
makes it super special so we're gonna
use the first gesture which is putting
your palm up just like this this allows
for auto tracking so right now it is
tracking me like this puts center stage
on macbook and ipad to shame i'm walking
around
look at this i'm behind the camera i'm
doing jake's job over here now but we
can find jake he's right here
like look how fast
like i'm over here
and then i'm over here
and then i'm down here i feel like this
is great for not only educators so if
you are taking an online class and your
teacher is using this they're able to
walk around the classroom so they're not
tied to their desk and they will be in
the frame like this is so great i feel
like this can also be great for
streamers there is a portrait mode
streaming version so if you wanted to
connect this to say obs you'll be able
to switch it into portrait mode and you
can actually stream in a vertical mode
which is pretty cool now not only will
it do the tracking of you but you could
also zoom in and zoom out you just put
up a little l
and then
when you put this up
it'll start zooming
and when you put it back down it starts
zooming out like it's keeping me
in the front like this is so great i
want to show you guys the hdr this will
obviously give you way more control over
editing and color correction in your
video so let's turn on the hdr hi hello
we're now recording in hdr tracking is
on
here we go so this is what hdr looks
like on and now i'm going to give you
guys a little example of what it looks
like with hdr off so here's what it
looks like with hdr off i feel like
depending upon what you're filming or if
you're doing conference calls you could
definitely get away without using hdr
man i'm such a huge fan of hdr and i'm
glad that they have it as an option so
you might notice that there is now a
whiteboard behind me which means it's
time to test out the whiteboard now i've
got these stickers which obviously i
didn't realize when i was doing my
unboxing that these were actually a key
part of making the whiteboard part work
so if you go into here you can see in
the capture settings that when you make
the letter v with your fingers or a p
sign that will automatically set it into
whiteboard mode and you put these in the
corner of the whiteboard so that it's
able to know the boundaries of where the
whiteboard is and this will
automatically enhance things that are
written on the whiteboard and it'll keep
it in focus so let's put these up one of
the things that this studio did not have
was a whiteboard so we had to go out and
get one today and you know obviously we
didn't have a place to mount it and so
jake came up with this he went and
picked us up a whiteboard and now we're
gonna put these in the corner so that
our trusty little insta360 link will be
able to know
where the boundaries are let's see if it
will notice that it's the whiteboard ah
there it goes okay so it just started
noticing it oh my gosh that's freaking
cool did you see that the whole board is
here i don't know what's gonna happen
i'm gonna just
i'm gonna write my name
okay it's finding it it's finding it
here it goes here it goes here it goes
this is so cool
can you even believe that this is
a thing like this is actually game
changing for i feel like a lot of
instructors
this is something that you definitely
would have needed in the pandemic all
right so i'm gonna give it the peace
sign to bring it out of
the whiteboard mode and then we're gonna
do another peace sign to bring it back
in to see all of this beautiful
whiteboard goodness a little flower
i love this
this is so cool honestly if you're
someone who this is something that you
would need for your school for teaching
i think this demo speaks for itself i'm
freaking impressed thank you guys so
much for watching i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and a huge thank you
to insta360 for partnering with me on
this video this was really fun to get a
chance to check this out and i'm
actually pretty impressed with how well
this performed if you guys want to get
more information about it i will put a
link in the description
but for now my friends i will see you in
the next video don't forget to like
comment and subscribe and be sure to hit
the bell so you'll be notified when i
post new videos i'll see you in the next
one bye
[Music]
you